there's something so magical about the
holidays in being in New York what do
you love most about this time of year
everybody can kind of be together with
friends and family for at least a second
yeah who would throw a better dinner
party midge or you definitely midge man
gets a great sense of joy and purpose
out of presenting herself presenting her
world presenting dinner I like to keep
things a little bit more low-key fair a
good party too I think
but since the marvelous mrs. Mazal star
has been busy filming season - she's
partnered with American Express to make
life a little bit easier so we are
kicking off the holiday season with the
American Express cash magnet card and to
me I'm hosting dinner here tonight and
the hostess with the mostest thank you
oh well we're keeping it super simple I
often don't have a ton of time to get
everything ready to prep and the cash
magnet card helps keep it super super
simple
you get 1.5% cash back on everything
from ingredients decorations
what kind of host are you I'm less of a
cook but I do have one super simple
recipe that is my go-to everything it it
has previously been top secret but I if
you go the et exclusive that's a secret
Brosnahan family recipe it's well the
cheese Mound
it's so so so easy and if you go to
American Express comm slash holiday
hosting you can get the recipe for that
other super simple recipes that can make
your gathering feel particularly fancy
and adult yeah you pull it out I feel
like you have to have what you eat
together do it okay ready 1 2 3 oh good
mm-hmm who do you splurge on during the
holidays oh my dog do you really I do
yeah what do they get I really
appreciate this yeah they I like to get
them in soft blankets and beds and extra
toys during the holidays